Bonjour à tous, aujourd'hui
on va parler des exoplanètes.
Ce qu'on appelle une exoplanète,
vous le savez sans doutes,
c'est une planète située en dehors
de notre système solaire.
Cela fait maintenant plus de 25 ans
qu'on sait en détecter
et on en a identifié à ce jour
plus de 4 000.
Évidemment chaque fois qu'on pense
à une exoplanète
la première chose qu'on a envie
de se demander c'est:
est-ce qu'elle ressemble à la Terre,
est-ce qu'elle serait habitable?
Ou du moins est-ce qu'elle pourrait
être propice
à l'apparition d'une forme de vie?
Ces questions sont évidemment très complexes
et j'ai déjà eu l'occasion d'en parler
dans les épisodes précédents de cette série.
Savoir si une exoplanète serait habitable
résulte de la combinaison
d'un grand nombre de facteurs qu'on
ne connait pas toujours,
mais pour commencer on peut regarder
deux caractéristiques importantes
d'une exoplanète:
sa masse et la distance qui la sépare
de son étoile.
Sur ce diagramme vous avez une représentation
d'environ 2000 exoplanète confirmées
dont on sait estimer à la fois la masse
et la distance à l'étoile.
Pour faire ce diagramme j'ai utilisé
une base de données
qui recense toutes les exoplanètes
découvertes à ce jour
avec leurs caractéristiques connues
sur l'axe horizontal vous avez donc la masse
et sur l'axe vertical la distance à l'étoile,
les valeurs sont rapportés à celles
de la Terre
donc ici le point (1,1) ce serait
une planète
ayant la même masse que la Terre
et située,
comme la Terre à 150 millions
de km de son étoile.
Attention, sur le diagramme les échelles
sont logarithmiques,
tout à droite on a les planètes qui sont
1000 à 10 000 fois plus massives que la Terre
et, même principe sur la ligne verticale,
tout en bas par exemple
ce sont des planètes 100 fois plus proches
de leur étoile que n'est la Terre.
Pour y voir clair, je vais ajouter sur
le diagramme les planètes du système solaire,
vous voyez que dans l'ensemble
les exoplanètes qu'on détecte
ne ressemblent pas trop aux planètes
que l'on connaît.
Elles ont en général des masses bien plus
importantes que celle de la Terre
et sont très souvent situées très proches
de leur étoile.
Est-ce que ça veut dire
que dans l'univers
il n'y a presque pas de planète
comme la nôtre?
Eh ben pas forcément, cette répartition
qu'on observe est surtout liée
aux méthodes qu'on utilise pour détecter
ces exoplanètes,
il existe plusieurs techniques assez
différentes,
avec chacune ses conditions
de prédilection
et c'est de ça dont on va parler
aujourd'hui.
[musique]
Naïvement on pourrait dire que pour détecter
une exoplanète
il suffit de faire ce qu'on a fait avec
les planètes du système solaire,
on essaye tout simplement de les voir!
Après tous nos télescopes actuels sont
quand même bien plus sophistiqués
que ceux dont on disposait
au 18e ou 19e siècle.
Et ben non, contrairement à ce que
laissent penser
les représentations artistiques
qu'on en donne parfois,
on ne peut pas "voir" les exoplanètes,
en tout cas pas dans le sens usuel
du mot "voir".
Pour s'en rendre compte, imaginons une étoile,
comme le soleil, mais située à,
disons, 15 années-lumière de nous,
vraiment pas loin donc,
et autour d'elle une planète
similaire à la Terre.
15 années-lumière, ça fait environ
15 0000 milliards de km,
et imaginons que la distance entre
l'hypothétique planète
et son étoile ce soit, comme pour la terre,
150 millions de km,
avec ces valeurs vous réalisez que mon dessin
n'est pas du tout à l'échelle
cette distance-là devrait être un million
de fois plus grande que celle-ci
et donc l'angle ici, en fait,
il est minuscule.
Ça veut dire que, quand on les regarde
depuis la Terre,
cette étoile et cette planète vont
nous apparaître
incroyablement proches l'une de l'autre
on peut calculer ça, cet angle vous environ
50 millionièmes de degrés
en pratique les petits angles comme celui-ci
on les exprime avec une autre unité
qui est la seconde d'arc, 1 degré est divisé
en 3600 secondes d'arc,
eh bien notre angle ici fait
0,2 secondes d'arc.
Qu'est-ce que ça veut dire un angle
si petit?
Pour s'en rendre compte il faut les comparer
avec ce qu'on peut faire
avec les télescopes actuels, plus l'angle
est petit, plus il va être difficile
de distinguer les deux objets sur les images
prises par le télescope.
Quand on parle de la puissance d'un télescope
un des facteurs clés c'est sa résolution,
ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'on va compter
en mégapixels
comme pour un écran ou un appareil photo.
La résolution d'un télescope c'est
une résolution angulaire,
c'est sa capacité à distinguer des objets
très proches dans le ciel.
Pour donner une idée la résolution angulaire
du télescope spatial Hubble c'est
environ 0,05 seconde d'arc,
les quatre télescopes du VLT au Chili
c'est le même ordre de grandeur
même si on peut faire mieux en les combinant
tous les quatre.
Donc vous voyez que, rien qu'avec mon petit
exemple assez optimiste,
on est déjà proche des limites de résolution
des meilleurs télescopes actuels,
c'est juste mais ça peut passer.
Sauf qu'il y a un problème supplémentaire,
c'est le contraste.
Il faut réaliser que quand nous sur Terre,
on observe une planète du système solaire,
par exemple Mars,
ce qu'on voit c'est la lumière du Soleil
qui est réfléchie par Mars,
Mars ne produit pas de lumière visible,
ce n'est pas une étoile.
C'est pareil pour la Terre, vue de l'espace,
en fait
on voit la lumière du soleil
qu'elle réfléchit
et on peut calculer que, pour quelqu'un
qui serait très loin du système solaire
et qui nous regarderait avec
un super télescope
la luminosité apparente de la Terre serait
un milliard de fois inférieure
à celle du Soleil,
il y aurait contraste de 1 milliard
entre les deux.
Avec la lumière parasite qui provient
de l'étoile,
même si on a la bonne résolution angulaire,
on a en fait presque aucune chance
de détecter directement la planète
avec un tel contraste,
c'est comme si l'étoile éblouissait
complètement le télescope.
Heureusement il y a deux façons
de s'en sortir.
La première c'est d'essayer de masquer
la lumière de l'étoile,
c'est le principe de ce qui se passe lors
d'une éclipse totale de soleil,
la Lune vient masquer le Soleil
et à ce moment-là
on peut observer autour des phénomènes qu'on
aurait beaucoup de mal à voir autrement.
Pour essayer de reproduire ça artificiellement,
ben ça n'a rien d'évident,
c'est pas juste placer une gommette
à l'endroit de l'étoile sur le télescope.
Il faut utiliser des dispositifs optiques
sophistiqués qu'on appelle des coronographes,
ça permet de produire des images où
la lumière de l'étoile est masquée
et donc de mieux mettre en valeur ce qui peut
se trouver éventuellement autour.
L'autre moyen d'améliorer nos chances
c'est d'essayer de détecter des planètes,
non pas en utilisant de la lumière visible,
mais des infra rouges.
Du fait de sa température une planète émet
naturellement du rayonnement infrarouge
comme son étoile d'ailleurs, mais
en infrarouge le rapport de luminosité,
le contraste, est bien meilleur, ça peut
descendre en dessous d'un million,
au lieu d'un milliard en lumière visible,
et là ça commence à devenir possible
de la distinguer.
Voici un bel exemple: en 2009
l'équipe menée par l'astrophysicienne
française Anne-Marie Lagrange
a mis en évidence de cette façon une
exoplanète autour de l'étoile β pictoris.
Voici une image qui représente la luminosité
en infrarouge
après avoir soustrait celle de l'étoile,
on distingue un petit point lumineux
qui, à l'époque, avait été proposé
comme une possible exoplanète.
Bien que la découverte ait été annoncée
en 2009,
les images utilisées, elles,
dataient de 2003
et provenaient du télescope VLT au Chili
En 2010 il a été possible de faire
une nouvelle campagne d'observation
sur le VLT qui a permis de confirmer
la présence de cette exoplanète
qu'on appelle "β pictoris b,
Oui, en général c'est comme ça avec
les exoplanètes,
on leur donne le nom de l'étoile suivi
d'une lettre minuscule b, c, d, etc.
Entre 2014 et 2018 on a pu prendre
de nouvelles images
dont voici une représentation assez chouette,
on voit bien sur chaque image
la planète et la zone sombre au centre
qui est celle masquée par le coronographe.
On peut reconstituer le déplacement
de la planète
et notamment son passage en arrière
de l'étoile
entre novembre 2016 et septembre 2018,
vu la trajectoire qu'on a,
il y a pas de doute possible, ce n'est pas
un artefact,
on a bien affaire à un corps en orbite
autour de l'étoile.
Alors voyons quand même de quoi on parle,
la planète serait une dizaine de fois
la masse de Jupiter
(3000 fois la masse de la Terre)
c'est un sacré morceau!
Grâce aux images infrarouge on a pu estimer
sa température qui serait de plus de 1200°,
c'est d'ailleurs une des raisons
qui permet de la détecter,
sa température étant élevée elle émet
beaucoup d'infrarouges
ce qui favorise sont identification.
Et pourquoi elle est si chaude?
Est-ce parce qu'elle est très très proche
de son étoile?
Et ben non, dans mon diagramme masse/distance
elle est ici.
10 fois la masse de Jupiter on l'a dit,
et on voit qu'elle est plutôt éloignée
puisque elle est à 8 fois la distance
Terre-Soleil, en gros comme Saturne.
Donc on s'attendrait à ce qu'elle
soit plutôt froide,
la raison pour laquelle elle est si chaude
c'est que le système qu'on regarde
est en fait très très jeune,
l'étoile et la planète auraient moins
de 20 millions d'années.
20 millions d'années c'est rien, le système
solaire, il en a 4,5 milliards.
Quand elle s'est formée notre Terre aussi
était à des températures très élevées
avant de se refroidir progressivement.
β pictoris b en est encore dans son enfance
tumultueuse et il y fait 1200 degrés.
Bref cette planète qu'on a pu observer
directement
c'est pas exactement ce qu'on pourrait
appeler une planète habitable
et les autres du même genre non plus.
À ce jour, ce sont près de 150 exoplanètes
qui ont été identifiées de cette façon,
par détection directe
et si on regarde dans mon diagramme où
on les trouve, elles sont par ici.
Vous voyez que ce sont des planètes
extrêmement massives
et plutôt assez éloignées de leurs étoiles.
C'est assez logique, on l'a vu, l'éloignement
ben ça permet de mieux les distinguer
sur les images.
Un point important qu'il faut mentionner
concernant ces recherches,
et c'est vrai pour toutes les méthodes
de détection,
c'est qu'il y a toujours un risque important
de faux positifs,
on croit qu'on a trouvé une exoplanète
mais en fait non!
Parfois c'est un artefact, et parfois
ce n'est pas une planète,
mais plutôt ce qu'on appelle
une "naine brune".
Une naine brune c'est une sorte
d'étoile "ratée"
qui n'est pas suffisamment massive
pour s'allumer vraiment,
en pratique une naine brune peut réaliser
la fusion du deutérium
qui est la réaction nucléaire
la plus facile à démarrer,
mais pas la fusion de l'hydrogène
qui est la réaction principale,
sa température ne monte donc pas suffisamment
et elle ne devient pas une véritable étoile.
On peut calculer que cette situation
se produit pour des masses comprises
entre 13 et 80 fois la masse de Jupiter,
au-delà de 80 on a une vraie étoile,
qui peut s'allumer
et en deçà, on a simplement une planète
géante gazeuse.
Il est donc facile de croire qu'on a détecté
une exoplanète
alors qu'il pourrait ne s'agir
"que" d'une naine brune,
le critère pour trancher, il est simple,
c'est d'arriver à estimer correctement
la masse,
au-delà de 13 fois la masse de Jupiter
ce sera une naine brune.
Comme vous voyez, cette méthode de détection
directe des exoplanètes,
elle reste difficile et surtout limitée
à des types de planètes particulières
et assez différentes de la nôtre.
À l'avenir pour améliorer la performance
des détections directes
les scientifiques vont travailler notamment
sur les coronographes.
On peut voir ici une animation
d'une proposition assez radicale
le projet Starshade qui consiste à lancer
simultanément deux satellites,
un qui contiendra le télescope et un qui
déploiera un coronographe
chargé d'éclipser la lumière des étoiles pour
pouvoir réaliser des images des planètes.
Dans les cas où le contraste est suffisant
mais où la résolution angulaire ne permet pas
de distinguer la planète de son étoile,
il existe quand même une méthode, analogue,
qui pourrait fonctionner.
c'est la modulation d'amplitude.
Imaginez qu'on ait une planète en orbite
autour de son étoile de cette manière,
si la planète réfléchit le rayonnement
de l'étoile,
eh bien elle va le faire d'une façon
qui rappelle les phases de la Lune,
quand elle est en arrière-plan,
toute sa surface va réfléchir
comme quand c'est la pleine lune,
mais quand elle passe en avant-plan
on ne verra que la face non exposée, comme
quand c'est la nouvelle lune.
Donc, même si on n'arrive pas à distinguer
la planète de son étoile,
que l'image est brouillée, ben ça devrait
quand même se voir
par une oscillation de luminosité totale
qu'on mesure.
Elle devrait être plus élevée quand la planète
est en phase pleine
et plus faible quand elle est
en phase nouvelle.
Cette méthode dite "de modulation d'amplitude"
a été utilisée en 2011
pour proposer la détection de
deux exoplanètes
orbitant très proches de leur étoile:
Kepler 70.
Cette étoile c'est ce qu'on appelle
une sous-naine,
c'est une étoile en fin de vie qui était
par le passé une géante rouge.
Les deux exoplanète candidates auraient
donc survécu de façon surprenante
à la violence phase de dilatation de l'étoile
en faisant même carrément un passage
à l'intérieur, étonnant!
Malheureusement, à ce jour cette découverte
n'a pas encore pu être confirmée
par une autre méthode et reste la seule
proposition d'utilisation
de cette technique de modulation d'amplitude.
Voyons maintenant, une des méthodes
les plus fructueuses
qui aient été utilisées pour détecter
des exoplanètes, la méthode des transits.
{musique]
L'idée de cette méthode est simple,
elle consiste à mesurer
la baisse de luminosité d'une étoile
lorsqu'une planète passe devant.
C'est un événement qu'on appelle un transit
et qu'on observe régulièrement
dans le cas du soleil avec Vénus, Mercure
ou même la station spatiale internationale.
Comme c'est une sorte d'éclipse très très
partielle,
vue de loin quand une planète passe
devant l'étoile,
eh bien la luminosité apparente de l'étoile
baisse légèrement,
pendant une certaine période de temps,
avant de retrouver son niveau précédent,
et l'amplitude de la baisse nous renseigne
sur le rayon de la planète.
Pour une planète de la taille de Jupiter
devant une étoile comparable au Soleil
cela correspond à une baisse de luminosité
d'environ 1%, pas négligeable.
pour une planète de la taille de la Terre
c'est seulement 0,008% de luminosité en moins.
La première planète détectée de cette façon,
l'a été en septembre 1999
par une observation de l'étoile HD 209458,
qui a montré une baisse de luminosité
de presque 2 % pendant quelques heures,
baisse à nouveau observée une semaine
plus tard
les observations ont ensuite été répétées,
avec le télescope spatial Hubble cette fois,
sur une durée d'un mois.
Prouvant de manière incontestable
qu'on avait bien là
affaire à une exoplanète qui transitait
devant son étoile.
À partir de ces observations on a pu déduire
le rayon de la planète,
un peu plus grosse que Jupiter,
et sa distance à l'étoile
environ un vingtième de la distance
Terre/Soleil,
on a donc une planète bien plus grosse
que la Terre
et bien plus proche, donc globalement
bien plus chaude.
Vous pouvez voir ici l'ensemble des planètes
qu'on a pu détecter par cette méthode
et constater que, dans la grande
majorité des cas,
il s'agit de planètes vraiment massives
et plus proches de leurs étoiles
que ne l'est Mercure,
probablement pas hyper habitables non plus!
Une des raison pour lesquelles on a pu
détecter ce grand nombre de planètes,
c'est la facilité d'utilisation
de la méthode,
il suffit de prendre des images régulières
de grandes régions du ciel
et de chercher ensuite si, parmi toutes
les étoiles qu'on voit,
certaines ont présenté des chutes
de luminosité.
Ce principe est celui de la mission spatiale
menée par le satellite Keppler.
Il a été lancé en 2009 et a scanné
pendant 3 ans
une grande région du ciel près
de la constellation du Cygne.
En surveillant ainsi la luminosité de près
de 150 000 étoiles,
Keppler a permis la détection d'au moins
2500 exoplanètes confirmées.
Bien sûr, comme pour les autres méthodes,
il y a aussi ici un risque de faux positif,
déjà il est possible que la luminosité
d'une étoile chute
pour des raisons autre que le transit
d'une planète.
Une première façon de faire le tri
c'est de rechercher des baisses
qui se répètent de façon régulière,
quand la planète a fait plusieurs tours.
Évidemment ça contraint un peu le genre
de planète qu'on peut détecter,
si on voulait voir un transit de la Terre
devant le Soleil,
c'est un événement qui dure seulement
quelques heures
et ne se reproduirait évidemment
que tous les 365 jours,
donc pas facile à mettre en évidence
plusieurs fois,
il faut attendre longtemps et regarder
au bon moment.
Ça explique qu'avec cette méthode
on va surtout voir des planètes
avec des orbites courtes et bien sûr
des planètes plutôt grosses,
pour que la chute de luminosité
soit bien mesurable.
Alors autre problème cette méthode: elle
repose essentiellement sur un coup de bol,
il faut bien réaliser que si on prend
une planète autour d'une étoile lointaine
ben, il n'y a que peu de chance que,
vue de chez nous,
elle transite pile devant l'étoile,
pour ça il faut que le plan de son orbite
soit presque aligné avec l'axe d'observation,
si l'orbite est un peu inclinée, la planète
ne passe jamais devant l'étoile,
de notre point de vue en tous cas.
On peut là aussi faire le calcul
pour la Terre,
si je représente le Soleil ici
et la Terre là,
attention les échelles ne sont pas
les bonnes,
la seule direction dans laquelle le transit
sera visible c'est dans ce cône.
Si un observateur extraterrestre se trouve
dans cette direction ou celle là
eh bien il ne verra jamais la Terre transiter
devant le Soleil.
Ce cône, ça représente environ seulement
0,5% des directions.
Si on prend le problème dans l'autre sens,
ça veut dire qu'une planète comme la Terre
autour d'une étoile comme le Soleil
n'a que 0,5 % de chance
d'être détectable par transit
vue de chez nous.
Donc le télescope Kepler a trouvé plein
d'exoplanètes par transit,
mais n'en a trouvé certainement
qu'une toute petite fraction de toutes
celles qui existent.
Cette méthode du transit a toutefois
un bénéfice secondaire intéressant,
elle permet parfois de repérer
plusieurs planètes.
Imaginons qu'on ait une planète qui transite
et qu'on ait une mesure assez précise
du phénomène,
si l'étoile abrite d'autres planètes,
même qui ne transitent pas,
elles vont légèrement perturber
la trajectoire de la première,
et cela pourra se voir dans les courbes
de luminosité et notamment
sur l'intervalle entre deux transits
qui fluctuera légèrement au cours du temps.
Un des premiers cas a été observé autour
de l'étoile Kepler 19,
on a d'abord détecté une exoplanète
par transit
qui produisait une chute de luminosité
d'environ 3h tous les 9 jours,
la planète a été nommé Kepler 19 b
et puis en observant un grand nombre
de transits
les astronomes ont pu mesurer que le transit
se produisait
parfois quelques minutes en avance,
parfois quelques minutes en retard,
et que ce décalage oscillait de façon
régulière comme on voit sur cette courbe,
ils en ont conclu que cette variation était
probablement due
à une deuxième planète, Kepler 19 c,
qui elle, ne transitait pas devant l'étoile,
mais perturbait légèrement l'orbite
de la première.
Et on connaît une vingtaine d'exoplanètes
découvertes par ce moyen.
C'est notamment par cette méthode
qu'on a caractérisé les exoplanètes
de l'étoile Trappist-1, un système planétaire
qui contiendrait au moins 9 planètes
rocheuses
ayant une taille comparable à celle
de la Terre, on en a pas mal parlé.
Elles sont toutefois situées très près
de leur étoile.
Et si vous avez bien suivi ce que
je vous raconte depuis le début,
l'image que je vous montre là n'est pas
une vraie, c'est une illustration,
ce qu'on appelle une vue d'artiste,
on est évidemment, totalement incapable
de faire de telles photos.
On va maintenant s'intéresser à une autre
méthode de détection
qui est une des premières qui a été
historiquement proposée,
même si on va voir qu'elle est assez
difficile à mettre en œuvre.
Il s'agit de la détection par astrométrie.
[musique]
On a vu juste avant le cas de la méthode
par transit qui ne fonctionne évidemment
que si le plan de l'orbite de la planète
est dans l'axe de visée.
La méthode par astrométrie c'est plutôt
le contraire.
Imaginez la situation suivante:
une étoile et une planète en orbite,
cette fois dans un plan perpendiculaire.
Si on pouvait voir la planète, ben on verrait
un truc comme ça!
Sauf que cette représentation qu'on utilise
habituellement,
elle cache quelque chose d'important,
on a l'impression que l'étoile est fixe
et seule la planète bouge.
La force de gravité qui explique
le mouvement, agit dans les deux sens,
la planète attire aussi un peu l'étoile,
l'effet est très faible
car l'étoile est en général bien plus
massive que la planète,
mais si la planète faisait, disons,
un quart de la masse de l'étoile,
eh bien voici à quoi ressemblerait
le mouvement.
Ce genre de situation se produit assez
fréquemment quand on a deux étoiles
qui se tournent l'une autour de l'autre,
on appelle ça un système binaire.
Dans le cas d'une planète, l'effet
sera évidemment bien plus faible,
mais on s'attend quand même à ce que
la présence de la planète
provoque un léger mouvement de l'étoile.
Et donc même si on ne voit pas directement
la planète,
on devrait pouvoir détecter les petits
mouvements d'oscillation de son étoile.
En pratique quand on observe une étoile
sur plusieurs jours
on la voit se déplacer dans le ciel
selon une trajectoire quasi linéaire.
Avec le petit mouvement d'oscillation
provoqué par une planète
on devrait la voir se déplacer
de cette façon.
Enfin ça c'est la théorie, l'idée paraît
séduisante et d'ailleurs
c'est par cette méthode que, dès le 18e siècle
l'astronome William Herschel
a prétendu avoir mis en évidence
"quelque chose "
autour d'une étoile de la constellation
du serpent vert,
même si ça n'a jamais pu être confirmé
par la suite.
Le problème en pratique, c'est que
les oscillations de l'étoile
sont très faibles et ne vont pas provoquer
des trajectoires claires,
ça va plutôt être des variations très légères
et difficiles à détecter
et ce sera d'autant plus facile
que la planète sera lourde
et que l'étoile sera légère
donc fortement influencée.
On appelle ça la méthode par astrométrie,
puisqu'elle repose sur la mesure
de la position des étoiles.
C'est seulement en 2009 qu'une exoplanète
découverte par cette méthode
a été annoncée pour la première fois,
autour d'une des étoiles les plus petites
qui soit connue, l'étoile Vb-10.
L'annonce a par la suite été contestée
par d'autres astronomes
et cette hypothétique exoplanète n'a jamais
pu être confirmée par d'autres méthodes.
Toutefois on sait que la méthode fonctionne,
elle a par exemple été utilisée
pour confirmer l'existence
de β pictoris b,
planète que l'on avait mise en évidence
par détection directe,
mais à ce jour cette méthode d'astrométrie
n'a jamais été
celle conduisant à la première
découverte d'une exoplanète.
Bien! Les trois méthodes principales
que l'on vient de voir,
la détection directe, le transit
et l'astrométrie
sont celles qui reposent sur
des principes physiques,
on va dire, relativement élémentaires.
Mais maintenant on va s'intéresser à
des méthodes
basées sur des concepts plus sophistiqués
et dont on va voir qu'elles ont permis
la détection de nombreuses autres exoplanètes
[musique]
La méthode dont on va parler maintenant
ce n'est pas la plus simple à se représenter,
mais c'est celle qui a été à l'origine
de la toute première vraie détection
d'exoplanète.
Il s'agit de la méthode dite des vitesses
radiales.
Vous vous souvenez de la méthode
d'astrométrie dont j'ai parlé juste avant,
celle qui consiste à détecter
les oscillations de position de l'étoile
et qui fonctionne en particulier quand
le plan de l'orbite de la planète
est perpendiculaire à l'axe de visée.
Eh bien la méthode des vitesses radiales
se base sur le même phénomène,
l'oscillation de position de l'étoile, mais
va fonctionner particulièrement
dans le cas opposé, quand le plan de l'orbite
est dans notre axe de visée.
Imaginez cette situation: par rapport à nous,
l'étoile oscille de droite à gauche,
mais aussi d'avant en arrière, ça signifie
qu'à certains moments elle s'éloigne de nous
et à d'autres moments elle se rapproche
de nous.
C'est la vitesse de ce mouvement par rapport
à nous, qui va nous intéresser,
on l'appelle donc la vitesse radiale.
N'oubliez pas que mon dessin
est très exagéré,
en pratique l'oscillation est très faible
et la vitesse radiale maximale
va dépendre des caractéristiques de
la planète qui orbite autour de l'étoile.
Prenons par exemple le cas de la Terre,
elle provoque une oscillation du Soleil
dont la vitesse radiale maximale est
de 9 cm par seconde, pas grand-chose!
Avec Jupiter c'est beaucoup plus important,
c'est une oscillation
dont la vitesse maximal est de
13 mètres par seconde.
Or, des vitesses de cet ordre on peut espérer
pouvoir les mesurer par effet Doppler.
L'effet Doppler, je pense que vous connaissez
c'est celui qui fait que la sirène
des pompiers change de fréquence
quand le camion passe juste à côté de nous,
eh bien avec la lumière des étoiles
il se passe la même chose.
Dans la phase où l'étoile s'éloigne de nous,
la longueur d'onde de sa lumière sera
légèrement décalée vers le rouge,
et quand elle se rapproche elle sera
décalée vers le bleu,
donc si on met en évidence des variations
de couleur de l'étoile,
cela peut trahir des oscillations
de vitesse radiale.
À nouveau attention, ma représentation
est très exagérée,
en réalité les variations de couleurs
sont vraiment infimes,
on ne peut pas juste utiliser un télescope
avec un détecteur classique,
il faut placer sur le télescope
un appareil spécifique
qui s'appelle un spectrographe et qui permet
d'analyser de façon fine
les différentes longueurs d'onde
de la lumière.
Le principe général c'est d'abord
de disperser la lumière reçue
en ses différentes longueurs d'ondes,
comme on peut le faire par exemple
avec un prisme ou en réflexion sur un cd,
puis ensuite de mesurer l'intensité
de chacune des couleurs.
Je vous renvoie à la vidéo de Syllabus
où elle en parle.
Évidemment en astronomie on ne fait pas ça
avec un morceau de cd,
les spectrographe sont des instruments
extrêmement sophistiqués
et lors de l'analyse on se concentre
en général
sur des longueurs d'onde bien précises
qui correspondent à des éléments
dont on sait qu'ils sont présents
dans l'étoile.
Si le signal est suffisant on peut alors
remonter
à des courbes d'oscillation de vitesse
comme celle-ci,
il y a deux caractéristiques importantes ici,
la période
qui est directement la période de révolution
de la planète autour de l'étoile,
et l'amplitude de l'oscillation qui va donner
un indice sur sa masse.
La courbe que vous voyez ici c'est en fait
celle qui correspond à la planète 51 Pegasi b,
la toute première exoplanète confirmée
dont la découverte a été faite
par Michel Mayor et Didier Queloz en 1995.
La période des oscillations est
d'une centaine d'heures,
c'est très court, ça veut dire que sur cette
planète l'année dure cent heures,
cette période permet aussi d'estimer
que la planète orbite à une distance
d'environ 8 millions de km de son étoile
soit 5 fois plus proche que l'est Mercure.
Quant à l'amplitude des oscillations
on voit que la vitesse maximale
de l'étoile est d'environ 50 mètres
par seconde
ce qui permet d'estimer la masse
de la planète,
environ la moitié de la masse de Jupiter.
Sauf qu'il y a une petite subtilité
dans cette estimation,
elle est biaisée par l'inclinaison
de l'orbite,
imaginez une planète dont le plan de l'orbite
soit à peu près dans notre axe de visée,
on va mesurer des oscillations importantes.
Maintenant imaginez que l'orbite soit
très inclinée par rapport à nous,
l'amplitude des oscillations de vitesse
dans notre direction sera bien plus faible,
dans le cas extrême d'une orbite inclinée
à presque 90 degrés par rapport à nous
eh bien on n'aurait presque pas
d'effet Doppler
donc rien ne trahirait la présence
de la planète.
Cet argument géométrique illustre qu'en fait
ce qu'on estime
ce n'est pas la vraie masse de la planète,
mais c'est une masse minimale,
celle qu'on aurait dans le cas
d'un alignement parfait,
mais si ça se trouve, la masse réelle
est plus important que ça
et l'orbite est en fait inclinée.
Pour avoir une estimation fiable de la masse
il faut croiser avec d'autres techniques.
Ce qu'on a pu faire dans le cas
de 51 Pegasi b
qui, pour le coup, est très peu inclinée,
initialement d'ailleurs cette découverte
de 51 Pegasi b a été accueillie
avec prudence par la communauté scientifique
puis confirmée par la suite grâce
à d'autres méthodes comme celle du transit.
Un point important, c'est que ce qui a rendu
possible cette découverte,
c'est la qualité et la précision
du spectrographe utilisé,
il s'agit d'un instrument en partie conçu
par Michel Mayor et Didier Queloz
et installé en France sur le plus grand
télescope de l'observatoire de Haute-Provence.
D'ailleurs, si l'histoire de cette découverte
vous intéresse,
je vous invite à aller voir le documentaire
"Chasseur de monde"
dans lequel Patrick Beau de la chaîne
"Axolotl"
a notamment interviewé Michel Mayor
et visité l'observatoire d'Atacama au Chili.
En plus de ça Michel Mayor et Didier Queloz
ont reçu le prix Nobel de physique 2019
pour leur découverte,
juste quelques semaines après la sortie
du documentaire de Patrick,
un coup de maître, je suis
totalement jaloux!
Après cette découverte qui a été publiée
en 1995,
la méthode des vitesses radiales a permis
la détection de nombreuses exoplanètes.
On peut voir leurs caractéristiques
sur notre diagramme,
on voit qu'il s'agit plutôt soit
de planètes massives
soit de planètes proches de leurs étoiles,
tout cela est cohérent, puisque ce sont
deux caractéristiques
qui vont jouer sur l'intensité
des oscillations de vitesse radiale.
Un facteur essentiel à garder en tête
avec cette méthode
c'est que pour confirmer le phénomène,
on a besoin d'avoir
au moins une période complète d'oscillation
c'est à dire une orbite complète
de la planète.
Et ça nous cantonne donc à des planètes
avec des périodes plutôt courtes,
pour détecter une planète comme la Terre
avec cette méthode
il faudrait une observation quasiment
en continu pendant 365 jours,
or les spectromètres sont des appareils avec
lesquels on doit viser une étoile précise,
on ne peut pas les utiliser pour surveiller
d'un coup toute une zone du ciel.
Dans les utilisations de cette méthode
il y a toutefois une situation
qui permet de conclure de façon assez claire
à la présence d'une exoplanète,
c'est quand on arrive à mesurer
l'effet Doppler
non pas sur la lumière de l'étoile mais
sur la lumière de la planète elle-même.
La lumière qui est réfléchi ou émise
par la planète
est beaucoup plus faible que celle
de l'étoile
donc il ne s'agit pas de la voir directement,
mais la vitesse radiale de la planète,
elle, est beaucoup plus élevée
que celle de l'étoile,
elle subit donc un décalage Doppler
plus important.
Si on a de la chance on peut alors mesurer
spécifiquement des oscillations
dans les raies spectrale de la lumière
réfléchie ou émise par la planète.
Ça a été le cas par exemple de la planète
τ Bootis b (Tau Bootis b)
c'est une planète qui a une atmosphère riche
en monoxyde de carbone
et on a pu justement mesurer le décalage
spectral des raies d'absorption de ce gaz.
De cette façon, on l'a dit, notre capacité
à utiliser la méthode des vitesses radiales
dépend notamment de la qualité
des spectrographes utilisés.
Ici vous pouvez voir une évolution
des différents instruments utilisés
pour rechercher des exoplanètes
par cette méthode
avec leurs lieux, leurs années d'installation
et surtout la précision
qu'ils peuvent atteindre sur la mesure
des vitesses radiales.
Pour le plus récent, celui qui s'appelle
Espresso
et qui a été récemment mis en service
à la Sillia,
l'objectif est de descendre sous les 0,1 m/s,
la précision qu'il faudrait
pour pouvoir détecter une planète
comme notre Terre.
Passons maintenant à la méthode peut-être
la plus subtile par son principe,
mais qui est aussi une des plus fructueuse,
la détection par effet de microlentilles
gravitationnelle.
[musique]
Pour expliquer le principe de cette méthode,
on va revenir un peu dans le temps.
Au début du 20e siècle Einstein propose
la Théorie de la relativité générale
selon laquelle les masses déforment
l’espace-temps.
Une des conséquences de cette déformation
c'est que les rayons lumineux
ne voyagent plus toujours en ligne droite,
mais peuvent se courber
au voisinage d'un corps très massif
et cela peut provoquer le phénomène dit
"de lentille gravitationnelle".
Imaginez une étoile ici, que vous observez
depuis la Terre,
et supposez qu'entre les deux se situe
une masse très importante.
Les rayons lumineux émis par l'étoile
qui passent à proximité de cette masse
vont se retrouver déviés.
La conséquence c'est que ces deux rayons
qui normalement n'auraient pas dû
vous atteindre,
se trouvent quand même courbés dans
votre direction, et si ça se produit
vous allez observer plusieurs images
juxtaposées de la même étoile.
En optique géométrique on parle d'image
virtuelle,
c'est en gros le principe des mirages.
Dans le cas où le phénomène est
particulièrement intense
cela se manifeste sous la forme d'un anneau
ou d'une croix
qu'on appelle l'anneau ou la croix d'Einstein
et qui sont la superposition des différentes
images de l'étoile.
En pratique c'est assez rare, pour provoquer
une telle déviation de la lumière
il faut vraiment une courbure importante
et donc un alignement quasi parfait,
si la déviation est trop faible
on n'observera pas plusieurs images,
parce que les images seront
en quelque sorte confondues,
mais ça se manifestera simplement par
une augmentation de l'intensité lumineuse.
C'est logique hein, souvenez-vous, on a
des rayons lumineux qui sont déviés vers nous
alors qu'ils n'auraient pas dû, donc plus
de lumière nous parvient.
C'est ça qu'on appelle le phénomène
de microlentille gravitationnelle,
une augmentation de l'intensité lumineuse
apparente d'une étoile,
du fait de la présence d'un corps massif
entre nous et elle.
Il s'agit d'un phénomène transitoire,
les astres bougent
les uns par rapport aux autres, et si
par exemple une étoile passe
presque dans l'axe d'une autre qu'on est
en train d'observer,
le phénomène de microlentille va provoquer
un pic de luminosité
pendant quelques heures à quelques jours,
et on sait calculer la forme de ce pic
en fonction de la masse de l'objet
qui passe devant.
Imaginez que ce ne soit pas une simple étoile
qui passe au milieu,
mais une étoile autour de laquelle
se trouve une planète.
Eh bien dans ce cas ce sont les deux masses
qui vont participer
à la courbure des rayons lumineux,
on va retrouver le même genre de pic
de luminosité,
mais la présence de la planète va se traduire
par une petite perturbation dans la courbe,
on appelle ça une "caustique".
Et donc si on observe un événement
de microlentille qui présente une caustique,
on peut conclure à la présence d'une planète
autour de l'étoile,
qui est passée entre les deux, et la forme
de la caustique permet d'estimer
certaines caractéristiques de la planète.
Cette technique à toutefois un inconvénient
majeur,
elle repose sur un concours de circonstances,
un "coup de bol",
pour que le phénomène se produise,
il faut littéralement
que les astres soient quasiment alignés,
et ça on ne peut pas le décider.
Contrairement à ce qui se passe pour d'autres
méthodes on ne choisit pas
autour de quelle étoile on va chercher
une planète, ça nous tombe dessus!
et si on observe quelque chose, on n'a aucune
chance de pouvoir l'observer une 2ème fois.
Par contre, l'avantage de cette méthode,
c'est qu'on a pas besoin de spectrographe
ou autre appareil sophistiqué, on observe
une grande portion du ciel,
on ratisse large et on espère qu'on va tomber
sur des événements intéressants.
Pour maximiser nos chances on va
plutôt scruter
des zones du ciel très dense en étoiles
donc on va pointer les télescopes dans
la direction du centre de la galaxie
ce qu'on appelle le bulbe de galactique,
à peu près dans la constellation
du sagittaire.
Au total par cette méthode on a pu identifier
plus de 150 exoplanètes
et vous en voyez certaines caractéristiques
sur notre graphique,
vous voyez que ce sont des planètes qui ont
des caractéristiques assez différentes
de ce qu'on avait par les autres méthodes.
Bien! si on ne compte pas les variantes,
on en est à 5 méthodes de détection:
observation directe, transit, astrométrie,
vitesse radiale et microlentilles,
mais il en reste deux qui sont assez
singulières
et dont j'avais envie de vous parler
car elles sont très intéressantes.
La 6e méthode c'est celle des pulsars,
je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
que la première exoplanète avait été
détectée en 1995,
mais en fait, c'est pas vrai, la première
planète extrasolaire
a été découverte en 1992 en orbite
autour d'un pulsar.
Un pulsar c'est une étoile à neutrons,
en rotation sur elle-même
à très grande vitesse et qui émet un fort
rayonnement électromagnétique
qui pulse de façon périodique avec
des intervalles
allant de quelques secondes
à quelques millisecondes.
Une particularité de ces pulsars c'est
qu'ils sont hyper stables,
la fréquence d'oscillation ne varie
quasiment pas,
ce sont de véritables métronomes cosmiques.
Le pulsar dont on parle s'appelle:
PSR 1257+12,
il tourne sur lui-même à une fréquence
de 10 000 tours par minute,
ça fait un tour toutes les 6 millisecondes
environ.
En analysant avec précision le timing
de ce pulsar grâce au télescope d'Arecibo,
deux astronomes ont remarqué de légères
oscillations dans la période,
oscillations qui correspondaient exactement
à celles qui seraient provoquées
par la présence de deux planètes
en orbite autour du pulsar.
Ils ont publié leur découverte en 1992
et on a depuis,
confirmé la présence d'au moins une 3ème
planète peut-être même une 4ème.
Évidemment, les planètes dont on parle là
sont assez différentes de l'image commune
que l'on a d'une exoplanète
et on parle donc spécifiquement
d'exoplanètes de pulsar,
et là a priori, ben il n'y a aucune chance
qu'elles soient habitables,
mais bon, je trouve quand même que
cette méthode mérite d'être mentionnée.
Et enfin pour conclure, dernière technique
la numéro 7: l'éclipse de rayon X.
Toutes les techniques dont on a parlé
jusqu'ici ont permis uniquement
de détecter des planètes dans notre galaxie,
la Voie lactée,
et même plutôt dans notre très proche
voisinage,
vous avez ici un histogramme de la distance
des exoplanètes que l'on a détectées.
Vous voyez que la majorité sont à maximum
quelques milliers d'années lumières de nous
et si cette galaxie représente la voie lactée,
nous on est là
et, en gros, les exoplanètes qu'on a trouvées
sont majoritairement dans cette région.
Mais la technique dont je vous parle
maintenant,
elle a été utilisée pour mettre en évidence
une exoplanète dans une autre galaxie
que la nôtre,
la galaxie M51, celle qu'on appelle
pour des raisons évidentes
la "galaxie du tourbillon".
Dans cette galaxie il y a un système binaire
probablement constitué
d'une étoile géante bleue et d'une étoile
à neutron qui se tournent autour,
l'ensemble émet une grande quantité
de rayon X
que l'on sait détecter depuis la Terre.
Or un jour, il a été observé une sorte
d'éclipse de ces rayons X,
ils ont diminué puis complètement disparu
pendant environ une demi-heure,
avant de remonter progressivement, exactement
ce qui se serait produit
si une planète était passé sur la trajectoire
des rayons X.
Alors il est évidemment difficile d'en savoir
beaucoup sur cette hypothétique planète,
mais elle aurait semble-t-il des
caractéristiques
comparables à celles de Saturne.
La découverte a été annoncée il y a moins
d'un an, en septembre 2020,
et il s'agit à ce jour de la seule exoplanète
annoncée en dehors de notre galaxie,
à 23 millions d'années-lumière de nous.
{musique]
Voilà c'est tout pour cette longue vidéo,
mais j'avais vraiment envie
de passer en revue toutes ces méthodes
et puis leurs subtilités.
N'oubliez pas de partager cette vidéo
si elle vous a plu.
Comme toujours vous trouverez des précisions
et des compléments sur mon blog,
dans un billet que j'ai rédigé pour apporter
plein de choses en plus.
Abonnez-vous, la cloche tout ça…
et puis nous on se retrouve prochainement
pour une nouvelle vidéo.
À bientôt
– Sous-titrage: Le Crayon d'oreille -